we also have a quote from I think Josh
Brolin and he says that didn't just get
a list of your Queens you're so awesome
thank you yeah okay two of us together
oh my god he says here that the fear
factor is always up here and he's
referring to onset and he says it's a
profession of humiliation sometimes and
you can get through the embarrassment
and you might find some magical moments
so does fear ever sink in when you're on
set especially with the last exorcism
too because you're carrying with them
this is you and do you ever feel this
enormous pressure I'm sure you must
because it's all resting on your
wonderful performance oh how do you deal
with that um I think there is always a
tremendous amount of comfortable fear
going in it's a vulnerability level for
actors and I think you walk that
tightrope you know and a lot of theater
it's live and it's raw and when things
start feeling dangerous and things start
feeling scary or there's an opportunity
to scare the audience or find something
unexpected or pull something out of left
field that's where things get really
exciting for me and I mean fortunately
with last exorcism part one and two I
have to give credit to the team involved
you know that's Daniel Stan for the
first film ed gass-donnelly the director
of the second film Eli Roth nobody does
like Eli Roth or comes up with a
script as compelling and strike
entertainment mark Abraham and Eric Eric
Newman and Tom bliss they set they set
the atmosphere that's set from the top
down and they create such a warm
comfortable set to try and to
collaborate so when there are these
exorcism scenes to go the full hilt
everything's playing every emotions on
the table every level of reality is on
the table you don't know who you're
dealing with if it's the devil if it's
real life it's if it's make believe it's
your past if it's yourself you know
what's out there and to run the course
like that they create a safe playing
so that you know all that matters at the
end of the day is the work sinking into
the work and they make that possible
you